[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA: Please help
me welcome my guests for today.
Deputy Legal Director of
the International Refugee
Assistance Project and
Visiting Clinical Lecturer
at Yale Law, Lara Finkbeiner.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, Lara.
Good to see you.
And fellow Googler and founder
of Rainbow Street, Kevin Steen.
[APPLAUSE]
So before we start talking
about the refugee crisis,
why don't you spend a
couple of minutes describing
what your organizations do
and what the goal of each
of your organizations is?
LARA FINKBEINER: Great.
So I guess I'll start.
My name is Lara Finkbeiner.
I'm the deputy legal director
at the International Refugee
Assistance Project, or IRAP.
IRAP is an organization that
provides free legal assistance
to refugees who are seeking
safety in third countries
like the United States,
Europe, Canada, Australia,
to name a few countries.
You guys have all seen the news.
We're facing the largest
refugee crisis of modern time,
and a lot of people
are stuck in countries
and still facing
ongoing persecution.
And because of that, they're
getting increasingly desperate
and having to risk
their lives by trying
to get on boats to reach
Europe or other places.
What we're trying to do
is to provide each refugee
a lawyer in order to represent
them in legal adjudications
so they can have safe legal
passage to countries where
they have a permanent
path to safety.
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA:
What about you, Kevin?
KEVIN STEEN: Well,
as Andre said,
I'm the founder
of Rainbow Street.
And we at Rainbow Street
are focused specifically
on housing needs and
other essential resources
for LGBT refugees in crisis
situations in the Middle East.
And so you can see us as the
kind of front-line defenders
against a lot of the very
real risks of bodily harm
that refugees face, that LGBT
specifically refugees face,
in countries like
Jordan and Lebanon
and other places where
it's particularly
risky to be yourself as a queer
person or a transgender person.
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA:
And now let's actually
talk about the refugee crisis.
And just so that everybody
is clear here, Lara,
why don't you start by telling
us what exactly constitutes
a refugee?
LARA FINKBEINER: Sure.
So a refugee is a person who
is being individually targeted
for reasons of race, religion,
nationality, political opinion,
or membership in a
particular social group--
and that's where LGBT
refugees are included--
and are forced to flee
their country because
of that persecution and seek
safety in another country.
And so right now in
the world today, there
are over 65 million
people who have
been displaced from their homes
because of war or persecution.
And those people have sometimes
crossed an international border
and gone to a neighboring
country in order
to seek safety, or
sometimes they're
just displaced within
their own country.
And we call those people IDPs,
or Internally Displaced People.
The vast majority
of those individuals
have no legal
mechanism to then get
to safety in a third
country because we only
have laws governing
people who have actually
left their country and sought
safety in a neighboring
country.
So that's sort of what the legal
definition of a refugee is.
I think the thing
to remember here
is that the vast majority
of these people--
this is particularly
true with LGBT people--
when they're fleeing their
country because of persecution
and going to a neighboring
country, a lot of times
are facing the same persecution
if not worse persecution
in that second country.
ANDRES MUNOZ
MEDINA: So let's try
to put some numbers into this.
So you said 65 million refugees.
And I'm assuming
that most of them
tried to come to some
Western countries, especially
LGBT people.
How many of them do they
actually get resettled?
LARA FINKBEINER: One of the
common misconceptions I think,
that people think that
refugees eventually
make it to safety in a country
like the United States.
In actuality, less
than 1% of all refugees
will ever get the chance to
get resettled to a safe third
country, less than 1%.
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA: The
chance to get resettled?
LARA FINKBEINER: Right.
So even after they're
referred for resettlement,
there's a legal adjudication
that takes place,
and not all of those
refugees are accepted.
So the actual number is
even smaller than that.
And so, of all the people
watching this broadcast
right now, if this room
was filled with people,
maybe one person in
this entire group
would actually get chosen and
referred for resettlement.
So it's an incredibly
small number.
What IRAP is concerned
about is that those slots
go to the most vulnerable people
given that the number of slots
are so low, and that
they have fairness
and the adjudicative process.
And so that's what we focus on.
And just to follow up
on that, a lot of people
ask me why is it
such a small number,
why aren't more refugees
getting resettled.
Refugees slots are basically
allocated by country.
So every year, Western
countries come together
and say we'll give 50,000
slots for resettlement,
we'll give 10,000
slots for resettlement.
Those numbers are really a
drop in the bucket compared
to the overall numbers of people
who are displaced in the world.
So what we're
seeing increasingly,
in particular with
the United States
now, is those
numbers are actually
getting smaller and
smaller at the same time
that the crisis
is growing, which
is putting individual
lives at risk.
And so that's sort
of the situation
that we're facing right now.
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA: Let me
try to focus a little bit more
on the subject of
LGBTQ+ refugees.
So 65 million, it's the
number of total refugees.
What about LGBTQ+?
How are they different from
the general population?
You said some countries sort
of try to make things fair.
Is being LGBTQ+ better for you
because you are at more risk?
Is it worse for you just
because you were gay?
LARA FINKBEINER: I'm answer
the legal side of that
and then turn it over to
you for country conditions.
One thing that I think is
really important to say first
and foremost when we're talking
about LGBT persecuted people
is that there's a
distinction between people
who make it to Western countries
and are able to seek asylum.
We call those people
asylum seekers.
So if you actually make
it to the United States,
you have the right
to apply for asylum
and prove that you
faced persecution.
But to make it to
the United States,
you have to have a visa
they go on an airplane.
And for most LGBT people in
the world, that's impossible
because, to get a visa, you
have to show significant ties
to your home country.
So you have to show
that you're married.
You have to show you have
kids, a high-paying job,
you own a house, you own a car.
These are all things that
are unattainable to most
LGBT people in the world.
And so that's really
an impossible task.
And so because of that, we
have this refugee resettlement
scheme which is supposed to
complement our domestic asylum
scheme in allowing us to do
adjudications of refugees
who are still stuck overseas.
So that's just sort
of the first hurdle.
LGBT people, when
they're being persecuted,
they're not really able to
get a visa and get on a plane.
So what they're able
to do potentially
is cross a border into
a neighboring country.
And I say potentially
because there
are a lot of folks who can't
travel safely internationally
even if they're just crossing
a land border from, let's say,
Lebanon to another country.
They can't go through
any kind of checkpoint
because, perhaps they're
trans and their gender
marker on their
passport doesn't match
their physical presentation.
And that's something that
could get them killed.
And so some people are
actually literally stuck
in their country.
And even if they make it
to a neighboring country,
if they make it to Jordan,
if they make it to Lebanon
and from, let's
say Iraq or Syria,
they still face a
host of issues there.
KEVIN STEEN: Yeah.
And that's kind of where
Rainbow Street comes
in is, similar to
IRAP, we are trying
to focus on the most like
vulnerable of the vulnerable
cases for queer people and
trans people in these countries
where it's really, really tough
for them to live, let alone
possibly travel or seek refuge.
And so we work
primarily with groups
of local activists
in Jordan and Lebanon
and surrounding
countries that are
focused on getting folks out
of life-threatening situations.
Really often, we see individuals
who are facing persecution
from their own family.
That's actually probably
the most prevalent concern
that we have for
a lot of the folks
that we're monitoring is
they may instantaneously
enter a really life-threatening
situation if they are outed
to someone in their family.
And in these places like
Jordan, for example,
where there is a really
prevalent social structure
based on family ties, that
really complicates that.
And so if you're going
to flee your family,
it's not really a
matter of finding
a different
neighborhood to live in
or even a different city on
the other side of the country.
If you're fleeing your
family because you're trans,
it means there is
a network of people
throughout the
country, many of whom
you may have never met before,
who are looking out for you.
And not in a good way, but I
mean they're hunting you down.
And that's the
situation that we've
helped a lot of our
refugees get out
of when they have opted to
leave the country in emergency
situations.
That actually happened
just last week
with a really young
transgender woman
in Jordan who chose
to flee to Lebanon,
and IRAP and Rainbow Street
worked together to get her out
as quickly as possible.
I think, though,
that so often there
is the misconception, not just
by supporters of this work
but also the beneficiaries of
Rainbow Street who are really
in these crisis situations,
that as soon as they
get to that second country that
their situation is going to be
a lot more secure or safe.
It's definitely better
to be in a country
where you're not being actively
hunted down by your family,
but folks who end up
in a second country
are exceptionally
vulnerable because they have
no support network whatsoever.
And so that's where we activate
our resources as volunteers
at Rainbow Street,
as we're connected
to a network of activists in all
these different countries who
are trained with our
case intake protocol
to learn exactly what the
needs of these people are
and mobilize to
get them housing.
And so all of our
assistance comes
in the form of cash stipends
on a monthly basis that
is designed to help people
get the housing that they need
and other services such
as medical checkups.
Trans people in particular have
a whole lot of ongoing medical
needs that cannot be ignored,
and our activists also connect
them not just to the funding,
but also to support networks
to help them find the safe
places in these countries
to live.
You can't just live in
any old neighborhood.
And so that kind of
holistic approach
I think is really,
really necessary
and really lacking
right now in a lot
of these under-resourced
countries for LGBT folks,
where there just is a community
but it's pretty disjointed.
And so we at Rainbow
Street are focused on
of organizing that a
little bit and channeling
some of the funds
from US donors,
grassroots donors, who
really want to help
and getting folks
off the street out
of that vulnerable situation
so that they can access groups
like IRAP.
If you're on the
street, it's really hard
to be able to make
appointments and be
able to keep those
appointments if you
don't have any money for
transportation, getting
in a taxi.
With the kind of assistance
that our network provides,
folks can access those
resources that connect them
to their long-term support.
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA:
That's great, Kevin.
You mentioned something
about local organizations
that you work with,
especially in the Middle East.
Do you feel that--
let me rephrase.
How do you think the
local organizations are
supporting the LGBT refugees?
Are they trying
to do a good job?
Are there enough?
Obviously, probably not enough.
KEVIN STEEN: Never enough.
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA:
Never enough.
KEVIN STEEN: There's
never enough.
Good question, though.
The truth is I definitely don't
know every single group that's
out there.
I'm constantly learning
about new groups that
have some kind of
informal support strategy
and figuring out
what I can learn
from them, what
information I can possibly
share with them from Rainbow
Street, kind of them connected
with our support
network in a way that
is secure for our volunteers.
Because you never
know who might be
trying to get more
information about them
for malicious purposes.
But in general,
there's a lot more
going on in the Middle East in
terms of queer rights and trans
rights.
Unfortunately, not a lot of it
can be focused on policy work.
In Lebanon, though,
there is a great group
called Helem that is focused
specifically on policy.
There is a law in Lebanon--
I don't know if people
are familiar-- that
criminalizes same sex relations
in really ambiguous terms.
And so there's like
a lot of legal space
to be able to kind of
reset that precedent.
And so that's what Helem
is working on right now.
They're the main legal advocacy
group that I'm aware of.
Maybe you know more
on that regard, Lara?
LARA FINKBEINER: No.
I mean, there are
actors in this space,
but I mean Helem's been in
Lebanon for a number of years
now, and they're definitely
at the forefront of this.
But in general,
there is not a lot
of space for
advocacy work on this
because it's just
simply too dangerous.
KEVIN STEEN: Yeah.
It's simply too
dangerous, exactly.
And there's also the
barrier of simply not
being able to literally
register legally as an entity.
And so, like in
Jordan for example,
there is Rainbow Street.
We have like a group of a dozen
caseworkers who meet weekly.
We have office space.
But we're not legally
registered as an organization
because that would be far too
dangerous to flag ourselves
to the local government.
And there are
other organizations
we work with, a media
organization called
"MyKali Magazine,"
who does awesome work.
They have this online magazine.
Everyone should check it out.
I think it's just like
My.Kali.com Maybe.
Search it.
It's amazing.
They do a lot of features of
queer artists in the Middle
East.
They publish in
Arabic and English.
They're really at the
forefront of this.
And Rainbow Street
gets a lot of referrals
from folks who contact
MyKali looking for support
for themselves as a queer person
who may be facing persecution,
or maybe just needs community.
There are also a lot of just
informal housing networks.
Especially within
the trans community
we see a lot of trans women
banding together and being
able to identify friends of
friends who are able to offer
a room on a short-term basis.
And part of our work
at Rainbow Street
is really trying to
organize that network
in a way that does not
increase the amount of risk
that people are in.
Because as you can
imagine, the more you
share with others about
these networks, the more risk
you're in of being discovered
by local authorities.
And so we are constantly
meeting new groups
of just informal
activist networks
who are working together to
secure housing and provide food
for people and trying to really
bring them into the folds
and organize it as
much as it needs
to be organized in order to have
more resources to refer people
to.
So most of Rainbow Street's
work is in Jordan and Lebanon,
and so that's kind of like
where my knowledge lies.
But I'm constantly
learning about new groups.
One for example
in Tunis, Tunisia,
called Dumge that is
currently assisting us
with a case, a trans
man who just moved
from Algeria to Tunis,
who is just kind
of like starting over and
registering as a refugee
and getting on the track
to eventual resettlement.
And that's a great
example of a group
that I had not heard
of until very recently
but is extremely well
equipped to mobilize and get
this person help resources,
psychological support,
community support,
housing, stipend for food,
mobile phone-- that's one
thing you need immediately
when you get in country,
and often people
have to trash their
old phones because who
knows who has that number.
And so I've been
really encouraged.
As I've done this work
since like 2014 or so,
there are always more
groups popping up
that kind of identify
themselves as soon as we
are in a crisis situation and
need support in a new location.
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA: We all
know that our dear President
Trump is trying to
pass this ban, travel
ban, executive order.
How bad is it?
How much does it affect
the refugee program in US
in legal terms for a refugee
that is trying to come here?
LARA FINKBEINER: Yeah.
The executive order has
had a devastating effect.
I think one thing that
hasn't been told in the media
is much as we hear a lot
about these six countries
where there's a visa ban.
But actually, the
executive order
also completely shuts down
all refugee processing.
So that applies to refugees
from every country in the world,
not just a set of countries.
And I won't go into the whole
history, the legal history.
You guys have probably
seen in the news.
There's all kinds of court
decisions coming out.
So I'll just skip to what
the current status is,
is that the ban is
actually in effect.
After the Supreme
Court decision,
the ban went into effect
with some limitations.
Right now, refugees are
not coming to this country
unless they can show they
have a bonafide tie to a US
person or a US entity.
What does that mean?
We're still fighting
about that in court.
The one thing resolved is that
if you have US family here,
then you're allowed to come in.
That's not a great solution
for most LGBT refugees
because they may have fled
persecution from their family.
They may have
strained relationships
with their family.
Or they may just not
have family here.
And so for example, a couple of
weeks ago, one of our clients
told his story in
"The New York Times."
He's an LGBT refugee
from Iraq who
was tortured by his
father for years.
And then ISIS basically
started to take over his town,
and he had to flee for his life.
And so he went to Turkey
where, actually, things
are getting increasingly
worse for LGBT folks there.
They've banned Pride for
the last three years.
KEVIN STEEN: With water cannons.
LARA FINKBEINER:
With water cannons.
Relatively recently, a
Syrian refugee, LGBT refugee,
was decapitated by a militia.
So obviously his life
is in danger there.
He was lucky enough to get
referred for a settlement
through the entire
US adjudication,
was accepted right before
the executive order came out.
And since then, it's just been
a series of getting his hopes up
once we get a victory
in court and then
having his hopes let down.
And in this article, what
he talks about is that,
after everything that he's
been through in his life,
the most devastating
thing that happened to him
has been this executive order
and having literally his travel
date, which is just like his
glimpse at a safe future,
snatched away from him.
And so it really is truly
affecting individual lives.
And even though this
is supposed to be
only a 120-day
suspension, 120 days
is literally life or
death for some people.
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA: This
fear, it's unfortunately not
only in US.
We've seen a lot of
countries in Europe
are also turning
into this nationalist
and trying to close
their borders.
So how are we doing as a country
compared to everybody else,
I guess?
LARA FINKBEINER: That's
a really tough question.
So traditionally, the
US has actually always
been the largest
resettlement country.
So we accept more
resettled refugees
than all the other
countries combined.
But that program is--
we set the number
every single year,
and that number is
set by the president.
And that happens around this
time every year, October.
And so we're hoping to continue
to be a leader in refugee
resettlement, particularly for
persecuted LGBT individuals.
But you know, everything is
sort of in jeopardy right now.
And now is the time
that people really
need to stand up and show
their support for this program.
This program has
been run for years.
The refugees that come
through this program
are vetted by 11 different
government agencies,
including the CIA, FBI,
Department of Defense,
before they even come to the US.
Refugees are the most
heavily-vetted group
of individuals that come
to the United States.
And so we've put
so many resources
into ensuring that the
program is safe in order
to keep this really,
really valuable
and vital lifeline
available to individuals.
And so I would say, to
answer your question,
refugees all over
the world are facing
sort of unprecedented attacks.
And a lot of it is based
on misunderstanding,
misinformation.
The US is one of
those countries.
The executive order has had
a really terrible effect,
but I'm still
hopeful, especially
given all of the response
to the executive order
by the American public, that
we can ensure that we remain
a country that welcomes
others, particularly
people who have been
persecuted for who they are.
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA: So now, I
think the question that we all
want to know, what can we do?
I mean, it sounds really grim.
We're just people, right?
What can we do?
LARA FINKBEINER: Yeah.
I know.
Sometimes I hate
giving these talks
because the situation does sound
really dire, but we at IRAP
are still hopeful.
Every week we get the news that
one client or a few clients
make it to safety and are able
to start their lives over.
Some of our cases that
we've worked on together
have made it to countries
and are flourishing there.
And so we still have
the ability to make
a difference in an
individual life,
and I think that's really
important to remember.
Because sometimes you see
this number, 65 million,
and it seems really overwhelming
and hard to sort of feel
tangible.
But it's still 65 million
individual stories
and 65 million individual lives.
So there's a lot of room
to affect individual lives.
If there are any lawyers
who are watching this,
IRAP actually works with
a really vast network
of volunteer lawyers
and law students.
We have something like over
600 active cases right now even
though we're a small
organization because
of our vast volunteer network.
And so if anyone is interested
in volunteering their time
to work on an
individual case, please
feel free to reach out to us.
Secondly, donations.
Even a small amount
of money can make
a huge difference for people.
Sometimes we have clients who
are kicked out on the street,
but they have a resettlement
date in three weeks
and they just need a hotel
room for three weeks.
So they need a place to
stay just for a few weeks.
A few hundred dollars can
save that person's life.
And so donate to groups,
especially-- groups
like Rainbow Street can make a
huge difference for a person.
And then I'll say,
thirdly, I guess
one of my missions in life,
this year in particular,
is for people to understand
that refugees are an LGBT issue,
and to make that part of the
conversation in our community.
And particularly,
when you're talking
to people who maybe don't know
that much about the process
or don't know that much about
what LGBT refugees go through,
it's really important
to sort of dispel rumors
and to talk about individual
stories that you've heard of.
And if you have
any other questions
or you want to talk
to me afterwards,
I'm happy to chat as well.
But we really rely
on people like you
to sort of spread the
word within our community
because we are stronger
when we stand together.
IRAP was the group that
basically started the airport
response after the
executive order.
We foresaw that there
was going to be an issue.
We had two clients who were
on planes that landed at JFK
two hours after the
executive order was signed.
And we put out a
call to attorneys
to come to the airports.
And I think we are
expecting maybe we'll get
10 people to show up at JFK.
Certainly didn't expect hundreds
of attorneys and protesters
to converge on airports
all around the country.
That made a difference from it
being a small issue where maybe
we got a couple of clients
out, to leading to momentum
to then address the
executive order in courts,
and win, and get
clients to safety.
So we really are
stronger together,
and I think it's a really
important time for us
to come together as a
community and to advocate
on these folks' behalf.
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA: Kevin,
want to add anything to that?
KEVIN STEEN: I mean, I love
everything that you just said,
Lara.
And I just love IRAP for
starting that response that
was able to really help
people in crisis situations
that they had no idea that
they were about to land in.
I think, in addition to
everything that Lara said,
there are a couple of
narratives that I think
are worth kind of engaging
with in our popular culture,
and some of them
are really, really
well intentioned, which provides
an awesome opportunity to kind
of work in a little bit of
education for our community.
And by our community I mean
the LGBT and allied community.
Because like you said,
Lara, systems of oppression
all benefit from one another.
And by dismantling
oppression in one form,
we are definitely
providing more space
for liberation for queer
people and trans people.
So I think the first
thing that comes to mind
is changing the narrative around
the situation for LGBT people
in the Middle East
in particular,
since that's where
Rainbow Street works
and where my expertise is.
It's really, really easy to
fall into the trap of discussing
LGBT issues in the Middle East
and in doing so inadvertently
painting Islam as an inherently
homophobic system of belief,
which is a myth,
depending on who you ask.
But kind of a lot of
different religions
or a lot of different
social groups,
there are so many ways
to understand that issue.
I've definitely seen some
super well-intentioned folks
look to Islam or look
to organized religion
as a source of these problems.
And I think that that can be
really unhelpful, actually,
because we're at a period where
xenophobia and Islamophobia is
really, really fueling
this anti-refugee sentiment
that we're seeing.
And so I really think
it's very important
to sort of engage
with those questions
and look to the groups
who identify as Muslim
and are in these countries
helping each other out
as evidence that this is
not a cut-and-dry issue.
This is not an Islamic issue or
a Middle East can't figure it
out kind of issue.
There are activist communities
who are working independently
out there, and I know a lot
of them and work with them
on a daily basis.
So I think being
able to really speak
to that is an
important conversation
for us to have as a community.
And I think, in terms
of discussing ways
that we can help, so often
like lots of people--
I live in the San
Francisco Bay Area,
and I imagine it's similar here
in New York, I'm not sure--
there are a lot of
great groups who
are focused on
refugee resettlement,
and a lot of LGBT
groups who are providing
funds and other kinds of
resources, volunteer time,
to connecting with refugees
who have been resettled
in the United States.
And you need a support
network, and that
is so necessary and
like totally do not
mean to undermine that
at all because that
needed to keep happening.
But often, I've found that
the conversation kind of stops
there.
And that by providing these
resources for queer people
or trans people who have
been resettled in country,
people may not be able
to see beyond and look
at these numbers that
Lara was talking about
and see the assistance
that's really
needed in first or
second countries
before people are resettled,
or maybe folks who
are eligible to be resettled.
So as a queer community,
as an LGBT community,
I think that we really
enjoy a lot of benefits
from living in the
society that we're in.
You were just telling
me this earlier,
Andres, and I really want
to echo the sentiment.
I feel so grateful to be where
I am in the United States
at this point in
history, where there
are a lot of fights
ahead of us, but we
can have these conversations.
And I personally feel like
it's time for us as a community
to pay it forward.
And I am really, really
encouraged to see
people who are donating to
groups like Rainbow Street,
but also other
groups like IRAP who
have specific LGBT
kind of programming
and are helping people get
out of these situations.
Because this is an
international issue,
and it requires an
international response.
And so while we focus on
our local communities,
we need to not let that stop
us from looking beyond that.
And so, of course
donations are great.
Rainbow Street is
all grassroots.
We've got a little
donation booth over there
if you're here in person.
And for IRAP, as well.
I know that we're accepting
donations for IRAP over there.
As a Googler, I give every
month to both organizations
and that gets matched.
So something to think about.
The other thing is, at
least for Rainbow Street,
I can speak to the need for
volunteers to give your time.
We definitely rely on
a network of volunteers
who are in country and can
provide the services that
are really crucial for
these LGBT refugees
and internally-displaced people.
But we also just need
to get the word out here
in the United States
about why this
is an international
issue, why it
should be important
to the LGBT community.
And sometimes that looks
like volunteer time
at a tabling event.
Sometimes that looks like
dedicating your social media
page to this for a while, which,
like, actually gets people
to look at it.
And as much as you can scoff
at social media, it does help.
And we need people
to help us research,
too, different situations
with different countries.
And so that, as we respond
to the needs of refugees
or other folks who
get in touch with us,
we can make informed
decisions about like, OK,
who is providing XYZ
resources in this locale?
Who can we begin to work
with in this new locale?
And so if any Google
employees in the audience
are interested in being a
part of any of those efforts,
it's not all tabling.
A lot of it is kind
of like research
and coordinating for the
more introverted among us.
Get in touch with me.
You know who I am.
And there is a
volunteer listserv,
Rainbow Street volunteers,
I think it is, at Google.
If you're tuning in externally,
visit our website site
Rainbow-Street.org.
That's Rainbow dash Street.
And we have a volunteer
portal for you
to sign in and say
that you're interested,
and we'll be in touch
as soon as there's
an opportunity in your area.
If you're feeling really
proactive, email me.
There's an info@rainbowstreet.
That will go to someone
at Rainbow Street.
And we can talk about
an event that you
may have in mind or any
other kind of project.
We're very grassroots.
We really depend on
the awesome ideas
of people who get
in touch with us
and really want to
share in this movement.
So I'm definitely willing
to listen and work
with you on that, too.
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA:
Well, thank you, guys.
Now is the time, if
you have any questions,
please use the microphones
if you want to ask anything
to Lara or Kevin.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Pat.
I work here on Google Maps.
So I guess my question is,
a lot of the conversation
is focused around
the Middle East.
Are there any scenarios
happening outside of the Middle
East that you work with--
I think you said
for Rainbow Street
you're specifically focused
on Lebanon and Jordan--
but anything that we should
know about issues outside
of that part of the
world, especially
I guess with the recent
news coming out of Chechnya?
LARA FINKBEINER: Yeah.
So IRAP, I say we're Middle
East focused because that's
primarily where the
majority of our clients are,
but we provide almost all
of our assistance remotely.
And so we work with folks
all around the world.
And I'll speak about
Chechnya in just a moment,
but I guess the thing
I would emphasize here
is a lot of what we're talking
about in the Middle East
plays out in all these different
regions around the world.
Whether you're
fleeing from Uganda
to a neighboring
country, or if you're
trying to leave Chechnya and
go to a neighboring country,
again, even crossing
an international border
doesn't necessarily make
you safe as an LGBT person.
And actually, I talk
about this a lot,
but I actually think
there needs to be
a lot more sort of direct
pipelines from your country
of origin to a safe country if
you're LGBT because sometimes
you're even safer
in your own country
because you might have some
networks or some people you can
rely on if things
go really south,
or maybe you continue
working and making an income.
All of those things
are taken away from you
when you flee your country.
But it's basically playing
out all over the world.
Most of the hotspots where
you see LGBT persecution,
things are not a lot better
in neighboring countries,
which are the only places
that can really access.
In regards to
Chechnya, the situation
has gotten a lot
of attention, which
has been really important.
We actually have seen a
number of countries step up,
and we've gotten
some folks to safety
in other European countries.
And we're in talks of trying to
help people come to the United
States as well.
So there actually has
been an encouraging sort
of international
response to that,
which is really great
because what's going on there
right now is just deplorable.
So yeah, to answer your
question, we are definitely
are involved in other
areas of the world as well.
KEVIN STEEN: I think for Rainbow
Street, as you mentioned,
we are particularly focused
on Arabic-speaking countries
because the genesis
of Rainbow Street
started with some connections
I made when I visited Jordan
at one point, and a close
friend of mine who ended up
in this life-threatening
situation,
and a complete absence
of any services
like this in the region.
So I can't really speak to a
lot of the services that are
available in
non-Arabic-speaking countries,
but again I've been really,
really encouraged to see groups
like--
I think the Russian
LGBT Network has really
stepped up and taken
a lot of the kind
of front-line load of
these folks out of Chechnya
who need support.
And of course, IRAP and
a lot of other countries
who've been resettling
folks on an emergency basis.
ANDRES MUNOZ MEDINA:
Any other questions?
Well, like Kevin
said, we're going
to have a couple of
donation stations over there
if you wish to donate.
It will be deducted
from your payroll
and will be matched by Google.
So yay.
Otherwise, please help me
thank our guests today.
[APPLAUSE]